or worried about grooming gangs and
pedophilia why aren't you outside the
courthouse of a bunch of white
pedophiles who are raping toddlers and
babies now you've got loads of people
like a Li Dao WA that have asked Tommy
Robinson that all right me your actions
are noble and they're good grooming
gangs need to be stopped but why is it
Tommy that you only target Pakistani
brown grooming gangs why not white
grooming gangs and gangs of other
ethnicities
now Skyy hey ask him about certain cases
of white grooming gangs now Tommy gave
the most porous responsively
and this is an understatement in fact to
call it a response is I think very
disrespectful to this word pure worried
about grooming gangs and pedophilia why
aren't you outside the courthouse of a
bunch of white pedophiles who are raping
toddlers and babies okay good question
let's say the response and I'm telling
you okay we're ready for the masterpiece
here that these gangs have been allowed
to do it for thirty years
what's that got to do with anything why
you know outside why aren't you outside
the Catholic Church or I despise the
Catholic Church how on earth is disobey
lead response mate operation you tree
have you ever stood outside an operation
you treat you have right no why not
because there wasn't no it's not good is
it because they're not Muslims no it's
not Gary Glitter you go abroad and rape
children in Cambodia
okay quite a few cases have been brought
forward let's see what Tommy Robinson is
going to say in return he has already
answered any other questions let's see
your job I'm actually unfortunately I've
had to come a fill a void and do your
job absolutely useless response Mei
didn't give any valid reason pathetic
Thank You Tommy for providing us with
yet more entertainment
I think he's going back in prison again
always coming back out one of the two
anyways guys don't forget to Like
comment and subscribe
we're nearly there at 100 K mark keep up
your support physical okay and until
next time
Salam alaikum
you